j'écris
la peur de manquer c'est la sphère
central de notre société
nous avons peur de manquer de manquer de
quoi le travail de salaire de logements
de sécurité de soins de santé de
retraite mais nous avons aussi peur de
manquer d'eau de manquer de nourriture
et même depuis peu de manquer de climat
consommer et je t'ai toujours plus à
consommer toujours plus à jeter
je téléphone l'iphone c'est le numéro 6
déjà le numéro un on a oublié sept ans
périmés la croissance ça s'appelle
la croissance c'est pourtant une bonne
idée produire et créer pour mieux vivre
ça pourrait fonctionner et qu'est ce que
nous en faisons
eh bien nous exploitons nous exploitons
tous des ressources jusqu'au gens y
compris les enfants dans des conditions
immondes en afrique en asie
c'est le royal plaza
on n'en peut plus de cette affaire-là la
croissance
me produis une société jetables
consommer je t'ai toujours plus
même la terre est en danger la
croissance ça ne marche pas
c'est une fatalité
je ne crois pas si la croissance ne
marche pas il doit bien y avoir d'autres
idées
halte à la croissance
vive la décroissance
la décroissance la décroissance une
grande idée partagée et partager quoi
partager nos salaires nos logements nos
retraites
nos résidences secondaires nous accès
aux soins et à la santé
peut-être covoiturer ou alors mieux -
manger ne rien gaspiller moins consommer
c'est la grande idée
alors qu'est ce que je vais en faire on
parle de sobriété volontaire c'est le
projet pour la société
écoutez bien une nouvelle idée un
nouveau concept ça vient de sortir la
pauvreté heureuse la pauvreté heureuse
vous vous y croyez
qui mais qui parmi vous a déjà vu un
pauvre heureux c'est à peu près sur la
décroissance ça ne marchera jamais la
preuve sur notre planète
la population continue d'augmenter
bientôt nous serons 10 milliards pour
tous ces gens là tous les besoins
primaires de première nécessité doivent
augmenter
on doit doubler la production de
nourriture la production d'eau la
production d'énergie la production de
soins tous ces produits doivent doubler
si nous voulons avoir une chance pour
vivre à égalité
sacré dilemme que faire d'un côté avec
la croissance
c'est la croissance des problèmes et
puis de l'autre avec la décroissance
mais les ressources pas sûr d'en avoir
assez
comment faire réfléchissons vous le
savez tous et vous n'y pensez jamais
ce n'est pas un améliorant la bougie que
l'on invente l'électricité alors eh bien
il existe plein de solutions
il existe des solutions vous serez sûrs
de ne jamais manquer au moins une
je travaille en agriculture je regarde
et je vois je vois la nature elle pousse
elle se développe en toute simplicité
depuis la nuit des temps
indéfiniment ça pousse tout seul tout ça
grâce un couple extraordinaire
un couple qui sait tout faire sur notre
terre il produit le maximum avec le
minimum avec rien ou quasi rien il
produit toute la vie sur terre il tant
il donne
il partage ce couple est extraordinaire
laplante le sol avec rien il sait tout
faire
comment ça marche et bien la nature à
quelques petits secrets
ce couple installe le cycle de la
durabilité produire consommer recyclé
produire consommer recyclé produire
consommer recyclé indéfiniment depuis la
nuit des temps
qu'est-ce que je dois en comprendre
qu'est-ce que je dois apprendre et bien
le carbone savez celui qui lie à son
métier il y ana d'énormes quantités du
gaz du pétrole du charbon que je vais
chercher et qui me posent des problèmes
dans ma société
par contre le carbone dans l'air
c'est un produit très rare le co2 il y
ana exactement
seulement 0,04 pour cent imaginez la
plante le sol avec ce rien la produit
toute la vie sur terre
c'est magique c'est bluffant
alors peur de manquer non regardez
que fait la plante est bien la plante
fait de la photosynthèse
ok mais c'est quoi ce truc là eh bien
elle prend le gaz rares dans l'air le
co2 est elle le transforme en matière la
matière organique
un arbre s'est plus de 99% de carbone et
en séquestrant le carbone de l'air qui
est rare eh bien elle va le donner à son
compagnon le sol
que fait le sol est bien le sol avec
toute la biodiversité associés il va
manger la matière organique
ils valent à digérer et il va la
transformer en gaz pour que sa compagne
la plante leur prenne pour un nouveau
cycle de production
un autre secret de la nature mon déchets
est un produit pour une nouvelle
activité parce que je sais tout recycler
même une matière rares gens disposent à
volonté
et c'est pareil pour les métaux et pour
les minéraux
alors que dois je faire
je regarde autour de moi et je me rends
compte que ce cycle là je pourrai le
copier en agriculture l industrie dans
la société
en agriculture il est déjà là les
agriculteurs arrêtent de labourer il
couvre les sols ils s'aiment directement
il double les rendements ils produisent
de l'énergie renouvelable
ils séquestrent du carbone il développe
la biodiversité
il supprime les pollutions le sol est
toujours couvert jamais travaillé c'est
l'entité de recyclage pour ne pas
polluer en industrie et bien l'industrie
a changé l'industrie innove déjà vous
avez des plastiques biosourcés qui
viennent de l'amidon il existe des
algues pour produire des emballages
recyclables renouvelables biodégradables
d'autres algues produisent du verre et
puis des bactéries qui mangent de la
matière organique produisent de
l'hydrogène de l'énergie renouvelable
dans l'industrie on parle de
photosynthèse artificielle écouter les
mots biomimétisme éco-conception
énergies renouvelables maison à énergie
positive ou bbc ou passive produits
biodégradables recyclage eh bien quelle
magnifique vivier d'emplois que la
société possède là
si elle sait faire une seule chose aux
et copier le cycle de la nature produire
consommer recyclé parce que pour
recycler
vous ne manquerez jamais normand iphone
j'en suis au sixième plutôt qu'un gros
tas de déchets comme cette annonce et
pourquoi ne pas en faire un produit
biodégradable la coque
elle pourrait être en fibres végétales
qui pourrait nourrir des bactéries
lesquelles produiront de l'hydrogène
laquelle en tant qu'énergie renouvelable
je pourrais utiliser pour fondre les
métaux et reconstruire un nouveau iphone
7 encore plus performant sans jamais
avoir un seul instant produit le moindre
déchet
comment agir comment continuer c'est
simple haro sur la croissance exit la
décroissance oublier ces âneries
la société doit copier la nature pour
son fonctionnement
déjà en agriculture c'est là en
industrie le cycle de la nature pointe
le bout de son nez
demain vous aurez tous les services
associés alors comment agir
comment s'en sortir c'est relativement
simple
nous consommons est bien posée vous deux
très simple question
la première suis-je obligé de consommer
c'est pas sûr je suis pas obligé
d'acheter l'iphone 6 je peux rester avec
le premier et puis si nous décidons
d'acheter et bien si nous décidons
d'acheter réclamant réclamons le
recyclage le biodégradable la bio
conception à tous les étages alors tout
seul c'est le zéro pointé
mais dix vingt cent mille cent mille
consommateurs à réclamer
il se trouvera bien un industriel qui
aura envie de faire croître son résultat
copier la nature
pour faire évoluer la société c'est
évident recycler pour ne jamais manquer
recyclé pour avoir assez merci